good e'en can you hear me very well
captain
going on they have no recourse let's
follow the captain boarded an issue but
from protocol so the [ __ ] sequence
activated
that's probably not good
you don't belong DC's legends of
tomorrow
hey everybody is Charlie this is going
to be my legends of tomorrow an arrow
combined video just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
we'll see how this goes
usually I don't like to combine videos
but if you're brand new to the channel I
do DC videos every week for the movies
for the TV shows be sure to subscribe to
get everything
there's a reverse flash ring giveaway
going on right now that I'll explain at
the end of the video but what I'm going
to do is I'll start with the legends of
tomorrow episode from this week the
Camelot 3000 episode then I'll talk
about the arrow episode because
everything is blowing up and everyone's
phases in the best possible way so it's
only going to get crazier towards the
end of the season so instead of the
normal top 10 WTF and Easter eggs I just
split this 5 and 5 for each of the
episodes so starting with legends number
5 welcome to the year 3000 so we learn
what happened to the Justice Society
they've been scattered across time we're
in the year 3000 in Detroit and rip
hunter is going after the spear fragment
the doctor midnite has made of a hat tip
to how we're going to meet the rest of
them I'm really happy with the Justice
Society this season I hope they find a
way to bring them back next season -
anything goes when it comes to time
travel
Doctor Who rules are that there are no
rules like you set up rules then you
proceed to break them each new season I
feel like if you've watched any
time-travel show even terminator breaks
its own time-travel rules all the time
number 4 the title of the episode is a
big Easter Egg for the Camelot 3000 DC
comics graphic novel so the story of the
comic book was very different from the
story of the episode so what happens in
the comic is that in the year 3000 King
Arthur and his knights of the round
table are resurrected and it becomes
this big space epic whereby Mordred is
resurrected in the future on a foreign
planet in the galaxy leaves an alien
race to invade the earth in King Arthur
and the knights of the round table have
to stop it if you have a bunch of time
on your hands I would recommend checking
the story out because it's super crazy
like the round table in the year 3000 is
in outer space like they had their own
Watchtower like the Justice League but
it's knights of the round table with
swords so it's super crazy but number
three this sort of feeds Ray's obsession
with King Arthur of wanting to be a
knight vs. citizen steals historically
accurate version of a
so he's like none of this is real he
starts making fun of the way they dress
you guys are dressed like you're going
to a Ren Faire I'm dressed like they
actually did back in the 500 so they had
a lot of great jokes but if you don't
understand how King Arthur was real in
the past is because star girl used her
spear fragment to create Camelot so all
that sort of like a fictitious but real
thing created with the magic of the
spear in order to protect it so she's
having a little bit of fun and
protecting the spear fragment sword in
the stone that was a nice twist with
vixen pointed out calling all of her
totems at the same time instead of stone
no fly
[Music]
damn those better
welcome back star girl Merlin I guess
they made her Merlin because she carries
the staff and it does look kind of like
magic but it's always nice seeing her
back so they rally they get ready for
the big battle ray makes as a lightsaber
Oh careful don't say that trademark
infringement I feel like the rhythm of
the jokes this season actually work a
lot better but a lot of it has to do
with citizens steel being a pop culture
person themselves and Ray being big on
pop culture usually you need to have a
couple of characters around so that
other people actually get the jokes that
they make like heatwave probably saw
Star Wars but that's just not his sense
of humor he has so much but my favorite
heat wave scene was in this episode
where he puts the mind-control device on
and it's just like I pity all of them
and he gives them all of his madness
just to shut down the system literally
the best part of the episode and the
most effective thing about it is that
you're just left to wonder what it was
that he actually showed him like what
was so messed up in his brain that it
short-circuited all of that super
advanced technology it just had to be
the worst nightmare imaginable so they
get to make heatwave look really badass
and tell a really awesome joke in the
same moment big epic battle and the
aftermath
they recapture evil rip hunter they kind
of tip the hat that they'll eventually
fix him but he's going to have a lot of
fun being super evil because there's
this backdoor to Gideon
so it's going to be utter chaos in the
next episode but they'll be going way
into the distant past in the explainer
for the two Sara's is that they're
actually inside rip hunter subconscious
so they have to fight evil versions of
themselves so that's what's going on
that's why there's two of them but
moving on to the arrow stuff everything
on arrow is getting burned to the ground
so I'll play the promo then I'll explain
what's going on in this episode and the
next episode where Oliver Queen's
administration might be over this office
and I'm Peachum hearing I'm a criminal
my targets the mayor disruption you want
me come on
so the episode eating everybody since
everything is getting burned down around
them prometheus backstory we visit his
mother they're still playing it like
this is just in claybournes illegitimate
son I know a lot of you have theories
that there's some other big twist but
for now this is the information that
they've given us and she says she feels
her son justified so she won't give his
name up to Oliver so they're just
prolonging the mystery who is his name
is it somebody that we've heard before
does he have a familiar name but I
thought it was really interesting that
she was super bitter about the hood
killing Justin Claybourne so even though
he was a terrible person she still loved
him so it's just interesting how people
can justify doing things when they think
they have the moral high ground
in speaking of which very timely Bad
Girls Club Prison Break this is sort of
like your intro to them bringing back
very Suicide Squad things they tease
that they can actually do Suicide Squad
again like the actor that plays Diggle
is like oh yeah we can totally do that
if we want to so when we hear a little
bit more about that I'll probably do a
video but the whole deal is a China
white which we haven't seen in forever
there was actually a couple of jokes
about that Cupid in Liza Warner released
everyone in there going after money from
Tobias charge hundred million dollars
and they're going to use it to take back
the city that's kind of a thing with all
the characters this season everybody is
taking back the city all the bad guys
prometheus is taking back the city
these girls are taking back the city
teen arrow is taking back to city so
everybody feels like they have the moral
high ground and they're doing the right
thing so it totally love the way the
writers set that up and the way that the
characters throw sins in each other's
faces all the terrible things they've
done so even though she left on a bit of
a downer moment at the end of the
episode like you're headed down a dark
path SIA was the wisest person in the
episode she gave the best advice about
not becoming the scene eater yourself
taking everyone's sins on yourself so
like Quentin was kind of doing that with
Liza Warner Oliver was kind of doing
that with Prometheus and the things that
happened to Billy and they had a great
big final boss fight in the cemetery we
got to see mr. terrific wearing a
comic-book accurate jacket he's been
wearing the fair play jacket but it's
been black on red in his white one is
just a little bit more comic book
accurate Black Canary is wearing the
matte
it was that nice moment with Quentin
where he gave her his blessing as well
as laurels blessing as well so we'll see
how that pans out I was surprised at how
fast they put her in the police
department so she is their person on the
inside now you kind of need someone
working inside the justice system now
that Quentin isn't doing that anymore
but number three the Susan Williams
Green Arrow identity plotline sort of
comes to a head it's not completely over
because she kind of knows who he is but
they effectively answer the question as
to what's going to happen and they take
it in a way darker direction than I
thought they would so there's this big
thing this season about trampling on
people's rights they kind of did that
with the gun control issue last week
Felicity tramples all over Susan's
rights of privacy haxor in a totally
discredit earth so it's also part of
this darkening of Felicity's character
and a Thea's character like Thea is
slowly becoming her mother little bit
evil with the best of intentions and
even though she seems really happy about
it
Felicity is darkening her soul a little
bit so we'll probably see some of the
side effects of that later this season
but huge WTF number two it got out that
Oliver manipulated evidence with the
district attorney to cover up Billy's
death so his administration is blowing
up Prometheus wants to discredit him in
the way they presented the information
in the episode they do make it seem like
Prometheus is behind all these big
twists the extra bit of evidence to turn
the police onto green arrow it just
seemed like it came from opal City so
unless there's some big twist this is
all prometheus so I don't think it's
getting overly complicated I do think it
was him to engineered this situation and
he's trying to get rid of all of her
because he knows the secret identity so
number one trailer for the next episode
is vigilante versus Oliver and if you've
read the comics is a bit of a
head-scratcher given what happened in
this past episode but it's basically
Oliver's fight with the vigilantes it's
kind of been going on in the background
coming to a head so maybe they'll be a
big reveal about the vigilantes
character we haven't seen him with his
hood off they've been playing it more
like an antagonist but technically he's
not Prometheus he's not a psychopath
himself he's just a little bit crazy
trying to do a good thing so wild dog is
sort of like the midpoint between Green
Arrow in
Sejal Andy they both love gun but wild
dog is just a little less crazy than
vigilante so you guys can let me know
what do you think is going to happen
with vigilante in the next episode
because there's one of two ways this
could go down they unmask him
and he becomes a true villain for Oliver
this season in addition to prometheus or
they take it in a slightly more hopeful
direction and he actually starts working
with team arrow
even though just like the Punisher he's
too crazy to be on any one team but he
is capable of working with people and
helping out for brief periods it's just
that he's going to be mowing down a lot
of people while they're all figuring
this out so I know that they're hyping
up this big battle between Oliver and
the vigilante
but remember prometheus is the truest
villain of the season and just a
reminder that all the shows are back
next week except for legends of tomorrow
and what's going to happen is is that
I'm going to be picking a day to do DC
movie DC comic book stuff just DC stuff
in general it is not episodes of TV and
an Avengers day but I haven't figured
out which days of the week those are
going to be it'll be like Star Wars
Fridays so if you want to recommend a
day in the comments just let me know
I'll post an update video with like
channel stuff like hey this is the stuff
that's going on in the next couple of
days maybe sometime next week but there
is a new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Clio Winn please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details what's
gonna happen next is I have a really
cool Thor Ragnarok video to post Tom
Hiddleston was going on and on teasing
stuff for the movies we learned a bunch
of information so I'll post that in a
couple hours
where you wait for that you can click
here for my Avengers Inhumans agents of
shield video and you can click here for
my flash episode thank you so much for
watching everyone with high five I'll
see you in the next video